Just before we get started
with today's video,
I want to thank of brilliant
for sponsoring it to
support biographics and to
learn more about brilliance.
Go to brilliant.org/buyer
graphics and sign up for free.
There's also a link in
the description below.
Hundreds of years ago,
if you told someone that one's a human
beings would fly through the air that
assume you were talking about witchcraft,
and yet in 1904 the Wright brothers
flew the first successful airplane.
One decade later in 1914
Jack Parsons was born.
While most boys of his generation
was still fascinated by airplanes,
Parsons was already two steps ahead.
He dreamed about building the first rocket
ship that would take men to the moon.
Of course,
back then,
this idea,
it was considered a total fantasy and
the 1920s and thirties characters like
buck Rogers popularize
the idea that humans could
explore the expanses of space,
but it was purely science fiction.
Flying an airplane is one thing,
but no man could truly go to the
moon and less they had magic powers.
Scientists and engineers from
around the world said that the math,
it's simply didn't add up and that
mankind would never make it out of the
stratosphere.
For Jeremy Parsons and the opinions of
all these experts didn't stop him from
trying to make this dream a reality.
He studied the chemistry necessary to
create a liquid rocket fuel that was in
fact strong enough to defy
gravity and for good measure,
he practiced a bit of magic.
Yup.
Magic is work would become the basis
of NASA as modern day space program,
but his legacy was tarnished by
his involvement with the occult.
Instead of being in the
limelight of history,
the memory of his accomplishments
was pushed aside for years.
This is the story of
the original rocket man,
Jack Parsons,
Jack Parsons parents' roof,
Whiteside and Marvel Parsons were
originally from wealthy families and
Massachusetts.
They moved to Los Angeles together in
the early 19 hundreds in 1914 they gave
birth to the subject of today's video,
marvel Whiteside Parsons
when he was very young,
his parents got a divorce and Ruth
Whiteside called her son Jack.
Instead.
Roof,
purchased a house on Orange
Grove Avenue in Pasadena,
California,
which has the nickname of millionaire
male because the streets are lined with
mansions.
Parsons was a bookworm and he enjoyed
reading Psyfari and instead of playing
outside and making friends,
he was so fascinated by stories of
magic that he wants trying to summon the
devil in his own bedroom.
Parsons wanted to grow up to build a
rocket ship so badly he was willing to do
whatever it took even
selling his soul to Satan.
Nothing happens,
of course in z later call this
experience a magical fiasco and he never
attempted to do it again in junior high.
He did badly in school even though he
had a bright minds growing up without a
father Parsons,
he was awkward around other boys and many
people considered him to be a feminist
and other boy in his class.
Edward Form in was also bullied
for reading science fiction books.
The two became close friends and shared
the dream of one day going into space
when they were in high school,
they experimented with fireworks and
homemade rockets in the Parsons is
backyards.
He was always trying to figure out
methods to make the rockets go higher into
the air.
The backyard was full of large craters
made from all of these attempts.
Indeed,
he was so hyper focused on
this goal that is grades.
They continued to plumbers Jack Parsons,
his mother,
she sent him to a boarding school called
the Brown military academy and the
hopes that this would straighten them out,
but it didn't work.
He was expelled for blowing up
on if the dormitory toilets,
Ruth wide sites father,
they'd been supporting
that lavish lifestyle.
So when he passed away in 1931 the
answer move to a much smaller house.
Parsons was attending college to study
physics and chemistry at the time,
but he had to drop out because his family,
he could no longer afford the tuition.
The chemistry classes he took in school
were enough for him to find a job as a
chemist at the Hercules powder company,
which specialized in creating gunpowder.
He owns $100 a month,
which is more like $1,760 a
month after modern inflation,
and he was also learning much needed
information about explosive chemicals.
He married Alan Northrop in
1935 when he was 21 years old.
He tried to save up money for tuition
so that he could transfer his credits to
Stanford University and it
was simply too expensive.
Jack Carlson,
and he was still really close
with that childhood friend.
We mentioned Edward Foreman.
He ends ads,
attended public lectures at local
universities to learn from some of the
greatest minds in the
aeronautics industry.
So that's a caltech
students named Frank Molina,
who introduced them to his thesis advisor,
Theodore von Karman.
He allowed them to have access
to the Guggenheim aeronautical,
the Barra tree,
which had been abandoned
after the Great Depression.
Once they had access to the
state of the art equipment,
they gathered a team of other graduate
students at Caltech to help them build
our rocket engine.
As they,
their experiments got bigger and bigger.
They had to move out into the desert
to an area known as the devil's dam in
Pasadena.
Their official name was,
the Gal said,
rocket research projects.
All the rounds campus,
they under the nickname the suicide squad.
Because of that,
near death experiences
experimenting with explosives.
They succeeded in
building a rocket fueled,
assisted take off rockets called Jato.
Soon enough,
the United States staff falls took
notice in this rock attention.
The government hired Jack Parsons and
does friends in order to create the jet
propulsion laboratory or JPL.
Years later,
this same laboratory would
become the foundation of NASA.
Possums made so much money at all of
this that he was able to buy a mansion in
Pasadena,
which he named the parsonage.
Hmm.
By Day Jack Parsons.
It seemed to be a man of
science and logic that all did.
His friends and family know that he
was leading a double life costing magic
spells at night,
and the hopes that the universe
would help his dreams come true.
He met the magician,
Alistair Crowley,
and became deeply
involved with the occult.
They believed in a belief
system called [inaudible] Lima.
The mantra was do what thou wells,
which was a way of manifesting their
wants and desires into existence.
Unless Crowley had grown up in a strict
Quaker household where his parents
raised him to read the
Bible on a daily basis.
Later in life,
he was able to attend to
Cambridge University where
it became evidence that he
had a genius level Iq.
He wholly rejected the teachings of the
Bible and focused instead on secularism.
However,
anything against Christianity
was interpreted as being demonic.
Crowley fully embraced this
as part of his identity,
calling himself the beast and attempting
to summon powerful demons to come to
his aid.
From the time Jack Parsons
was experimenting with
rockets in his backyard as a
kid,
the idea that man could actually
go into space was still a fantasy.
Many people refuse to believe that it
could one day be real and while it's hard
for us to imagine now the mere suggestion
that man could reach the moon was
considered to be rather simple.
While fell.
Oma has plenty of spooky and
paranormal elements to their religion.
Their core belief system was actually not
too far away from many new age beliefs
and modern day publications like the
secret which calls the concept of the law
of attraction practitioners of the
Lima did they in fact believe in magic,
but it wasn't just card
tricks and parlor games.
They practiced sex magic,
which is exactly what it sounds like.
They believe that the intense feeling
people have while having an orgasm opens
the gate to the universe.
They believed that in that
small window of opportunity,
it is possible for a human
being to perform a magic spell.
Well,
they really needed to do to perform.
This spell was to focus on their intention
while having sex and then wish would
come true because it was
put out into the universe.
Jack Parsons became the leader of his
own group and they would have huge sex
magic orgies and his mansion in Pasadena.
Not surprisingly,
Parsons,
his wife did not enjoy
this sort of lifestyle,
so she left him.
He began to have an affair
with his wife's sister,
Sarah Northrop Hollister.
We believed very strongly in the occult,
unlike her sister.
She actually enjoyed participating in
these orgies and Jack Parsons was just one
of many men in the group that she
would practice sex magic with.
While it may not surprise anyone,
Alistair Crowley was addicted to Saxons,
multiple orgasms in one day.
We're no longer enough to satisfy him.
He experimented with drugs and he
eventually became addicted to heroin,
which was his downfall.
As one of Jack Parsons meetings,
he and Sarah Hollister mad say,
science fiction writer
named l Ron Hubbard.
If that name sounds familiar to you,
it's because Howard would go on
to found the cult of Scientology,
but at this time he was one of the very
few saifai writers who were writing in
such detail about the possibility
of sending humans into space.
As a hardcore Scifi nerd,
Jack Parsons was thrilled to meet l Ron
Hubbard and invited him to join in on
their parties as much as he wants it.
Parsons believed that he could
summon a goddess named Babylon.
She has described as being the great
mother of the earth and a symbol of
sexually liberated women.
He asked his followers do participate
in a project called the Babylon working.
He thought through all of
these sex magic rituals,
the scarlet woman would come along
to give birth to the moon child.
They believed that this child could
be raised to aspire to travel to space
instead of holding onto the comforts of
bath if they never actually gave birth
to a real baby because they hoped that
this would be more of a symbolic gesture
for future generations of mankind's.
A scarlet woman was a symbol of free
love throughout the world so people could
have sex outside of marriage more openly.
In a way,
you could actually say that this spell
actually worked just a few years later.
The United States entered the space race
in the entire world's turned on their
televisions to watch the first steps onto
the moon in the 1960s the hippies then
spread the free love movement
that Parsons had hoped for.
Maybe just maybe all of that sex
magic actually ended up working
after discovering his ties to the occult
in the late Forties Jack Parsons was
fired from his job at the
Jet Propulsion Laboratory.
Since he was down on his luck.
L Ron Hubbard asked Jack Parsons if he
would be interested in partnering in a
Boot Business in Florida.
Parsons gave hobbits $20,000 to start the
business and Sarah Lester asked if she
could go to after stealing his
girlfriends and robbing him,
blind Parsons realized that he'd made
a terrible mistake by trusting him.
At this point,
l Ron Hubbard did create a
successful boating business,
but he never paid the money back.
Jack Parsons out to go to
court to get his $20,000.
Years later,
I'll,
Ron Hubbard would become the founder of
his own religion called Scientology and
he used this boat business
to create a sea org.
He borrowed much of the same principles
taught by Alistair Crowley and Jack
Parsons about setting intentions and
being the best person you can be.
He also mixed in his own fictional ideas
made up in his science fiction novels,
even though Sarah Hollister left
Jack Parsons to Mary l Ron Hubbard,
there were plenty of other women in the
group who practically worshiped him.
He mass an actress and artists
named Marjorie Cameron.
Just like all of his other intentions.
He had put his ideas about an elements
or woman out into the universe,
so when he met her he believed
that they were soulmates.
They were so intensely attracted to one
another when they first met that they
spent two weeks straight
making love in his bedroom.
He married Cameron in 1946 Marjorie
Cameron was more than a tad bit eccentric.
She claims that she had visions of the
coming apocalypse and she created artwork
about how a cults beliefs that would
later become popular during the beat
generation.
The 1950s was the beginning
of the McCarthy era where
the FBI was investigating
anyone under suspicion of having
ties to the communist party.
They began to investigate Jack Parsons
due to the fact that he took documents
saying from his new
employer aircraft company,
they suspected that he may be supplying
the USS all with these documents about
rocket engines.
After learning,
he was under investigation.
Jack Parsons voluntarily showed up at
the FBI offices in Los Angeles to explain
that he took the documents home because
he wanted to give examples of his past
work to apply to a job in Israel.
The FBI at this point thought that he
could actually be a spy for the Israeli
government.
He was fired from the Hughes Aircraft
Company and this was enough to blacklist
him from ever guessing another
aeronautical drop again.
Declassified documents reveal that the
FBI had been following Jack Parsons
movements since 1948 because it
is a cult ties to us to Crowley.
They believe that this was a subversive
group and it's considered to be
dangerous.
They were simply waiting for a moment
where he might've slept up in 1951 in
Parsons career was over and his marriage
to Marjorie Cameron was falling apart,
so they separated.
Jack Parsons was no longer
ranking in huge paychecks.
He occasionally works as an explosives
consultants on the sets of Hollywood
action films,
but these gigs were few and far between
he and to work the night shift at a gas
station and he rented out the spare
rooms in his house for extra income.
In June of 1952 Parsons received an
order from a film set to create several
explosives for a movie.
They asked him to hurry because they
were running on a tight schedule.
One of his tenants jokes,
be careful or your blow us all up.
Parsons responded with a chocolate and
said that everything would be fine.
An hour later,
the lab exploded.
He was still alive,
but half of his face had been
blown off from an explosion.
It was rushed to the hospital,
but he died from his injuries.
Just 37 years old.
His official cause of death
had been ruled as an accidents,
but many elements of the
explosion ops around it,
a mystery.
He had so many years of mixing
chemicals and creating bombs.
People find it hard to believe that Jack
Parsons could have made such a careless
mistake,
something that maybe it was feeling
so low that he wanted to kill himself,
but if Parsons intention
truly wants to commit suicide,
he would have known how to build a bomb
that would have killed himself instantly
instead of suffering in the hospital.
Some people speculate that
someone wanted him dead ends.
They snuck into his lab to
tamper with this chemicals.
The idea that he was assassinated
by the government is a conspiracy,
but it certainly does make a lot of sense.
It seems almost too convenient that Jack
Parsons blew himself up at the start of
the Cold War.
He knew plenty of government secrets
about that fledgling space program and he
was already showing signs of
wanting to flee the country.
Parsons truly was a genius capable of
building a bigger and better Rawkus than
the ones created by the u s government,
and they may have feared that he
would sell his services to the USSR.
The fact that Jack Parsons credited his
work with the occult for a success in
rocket science was an embarrassment
the rest of the aeronautical community.
If the public knew about this,
it would completely ruin the credibility
of the government's attempts to build a
space program,
but they were already having a hard time
raising taxpayer dollars without some
guy chatting about sex magic.
Sadly,
the program and is a lot more credibility
you want to see was out of the picture
after his death.
NASA would name one if the craters
on the moon after Jack Parsons only.
It was on the dark side.
This is very much how they felt about
his contribution to rocket science,
but they wanted to give
credit where credit is due,
but many wanted to keep his memory out
of the limelight while he was alive.
Jack Parsons,
his ultimate goal was to have his
rocket experiments succeed not just for
himself,
but for future generations.
He wanted the whole world to look to
the stars and know that it could be a
reality and not just some fantasy
written about in a Scifi novel,
whether you believe in the supernatural
Nazi in a way past and sex magic spell
is actually worked because all of his
intentions that he sat out into the
universe eventually came true.
Tragically,
he did not live long enough to
see NASA send demand to the moon,
but if he was watching
from across the universe,
it would surely be proud and if you
want to learn a bit about the real stuff
that Parsons was interested in,
a great way to do that
is through brilliance.
We talked a lot about rocket science
in today's video and while this is
certainly a complex subject,
it is one that brilliant make
really easy to get to grips with.
The way brilliant works is through
something called active learning and it's
really super effective.
Basically what this means is that you're
not spending time reading about how
something works,
looking at complex equations,
etc. Basically going over it again and
again and again until it gets in your
head.
For me often.
That's something that gets
just really frustrating.
I know a lot of people feel the same way.
Taking rocket physics as an example,
rather than showing you something
really complex and explaining it,
it all starts with something super simple.
You just have to solve a
puzzle related to the topic.
It's great to see how you do a few of
these puzzles and just a few minutes later
you find yourself saying,
oh,
so that's what the side
of the equation works.
It's very cool and as someone
without a background in science,
I pretty much started off thinking,
yeah,
guys in not getting to be able
to explain that equation to me,
but just a few interactive puzzles,
lace.
I'm like,
Oh,
well now I get it.
That's pretty cool.
It really is just like that.
It's kind of a weird way
to describe the process.
I know,
but that's how it works.
It's really interesting
how the information and has
your head through this way
of active learning.
It's a great way to learn and to
support biographics and learn more about
brilliance.
Please go to brilliant.org/biographics
and sign up for free.
And also the first 200 people
that go through that link,
we'll get 20% off the
annual premium subscription.
So it was always,
thank you so much for watching this video.
Do subscribe for more,
do check out brilliance,
and as always,
thank you for watching.